[Música]
un pequeño dominicano llamado Damián se
convirtió en el habitante número 8000
millones así lo anunció la Organización
de las Naciones Unidas es un hito muy
importante en el desarrollo de la
humanidad representa una muestra del
avance que hemos tenido en la humanidad
en cuanto a calidad de vida salud
pública nutrición higiene incluso
tecnología también es representativo
porque este anuncio tiene lugar en plena
Cumbre climática del cop 27 en medio de
una emergencia climática y cuando
estamos en una lucha frente a frente
contra el cambio climático así lo dio a
conocer la ONU al mundo entero veamos
da testimonio de los avances científicos
y las mejoras que se consiguieron en
materia de nutrición salud pública y
saneamiento sin embargo a medida que
aumenta la familia humana también se
vuelve más dividida miles de millones de
personas tienen graves dificultades
cientos de millones pasan hambre e
incluso hambruna hay cantidades sin
precedentes de personas en tránsito en
busca de oportunidades y tratando de
superar deudas y penurias guerras y
desastres climáticos A menos que
reduzcamos el enorme Abismo entre los
que tienen y los que no tienen estamos
allanando el camino hacia un mundo con
8.000 millones de habitantes dominado
por tensiones y desconfianza crisis y
conflicto
Sin lugar a dudas el crecimiento de la
población representa grandes desafíos
para los gobiernos para los estados de
bienestar En aquellos países donde están
establecidos Y por supuesto para los
países más pobres veamos entonces Cuáles
son los países más poblados del mundo el
primer lugar lo ocupa china con más de
1452 millones de habitantes le sigue
India ambos países están en el
continente asiático en tercera posición
está Estados Unidos le sigue India y
cierra ese top 5 Brasil que es el primer
país de América del Sur en Entrar en
este top 5 continuamos desde el 5 hasta
el 10 en este top 10 en el sexto puesto
está Pakistán le sigue Nigeria que sería
el primer país del continente africano
entre los más poblados del mundo le
sigue bangladesh Rusia y cierra la
décima posición México que es el primer
país latino americano en estar en este
top 10 justamente ese top 10 si hacemos
balance son cinco países asiáticos 1
euro asiático estamos hablando del caso
de Rusia tres son americanos y uno es
africano pero ahora veamos los países
menos poblados el país menos poblado del
mundo es la ciudad del Vaticano le sigue
tuvalu le sigue Mauro Palau Y que todos
son estados insulares que están ubicados
en el océano Pacífico y que hay que
decir son países que están en riesgo de
desaparecer ante un posible incremento
considerable del nivel de los océanos
debido al calentamiento global global
cierra este top 5 San Marino que es un
país que está ubicado en el sur de
Europa Cuáles son entonces las
estimaciones para el 2023 se espera que
India supere a China como el país más
poblado del mundo según las estimaciones
de la Organización de las Naciones
Unidas este mismo organismo
internacional también proyecta para el
2056 que la población llegará a los 10
mil millones de habitantes Qué significa
entonces para el mundo haber llegado el
día de hoy a los 8000 millones
habitantes este crecimiento demográfico
rápido y constante dependiendo de las
épocas que hemos tenido a lo largo de
los últimos años que implica a nivel
medioambiental a nivel económico qué
preocupación debemos tener en cuanto al
consumo de los recursos materiales que
ya de hecho estamos en déficit Y cómo
puede haber una mejor redistribución de
ingresos para dar las mismas garantías
para todos los habitantes por eso hoy en
el debate de France 24 que impacto
tienen los 8.000 millones de habitantes
en nuestro planeta para analizar este
tema hemos invitado a Pablo Salazar él
es el representante de unfa en Guatemala
también está con nosotros Oscar Javier
Maldonado él es pH 10 profesora asociado
del programa de sociología de la
Universidad del Rosario que está ubicada
en la ciudad de Bogotá en Colombia
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
hacen parte de este debate pueden dejar
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las diferentes redes sociales estamos
en Twitter en Facebook también en
Instagram nos encuentran como arroba el
debate f24 o arroba el debate guión bajo
f24 Mejor dicho y @santilogo que es mi
cuenta personal la etiqueta numeral el
debate f24 todo Unido todo pegado no
olvide también que todos nuestros
contenidos están disponibles en
diferentes plataformas de podcast
estamos en Apple podcast en Spotify en
deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a mi primer invitado a Pablo Salazar y
preguntándole Pablo Cómo llegamos a esta
cifra qué análisis se puede hacer al
respecto qué condiciones se reunieron se
dieron a lo largo de los últimos años de
la historia de la humanidad que permitió
llegar a 8 mil millones de habitantes en
nuestro planeta bienvenido
Muchas gracias Santiago
básicamente es un proceso que se llama
la transición demográfica Entonces el
proceso de la transición demográfica es
un proceso en el cual primero caen
rápidamente La las tasas de mortalidad
entonces básicamente los cambios de la
ciencia la invención de las vacunas las
mejoras sanitarias generaron un
incremento sustancial de esperanza de
vida al nacer en toda la humanidad este
momento hablamos de esperanzas de vida
que bordeándose entre los 70 y los 80
años en el mundo promedio y cuando a
finales del siglo 19 hablábamos de 30
años de esperanza de vida entonces todo
este cambio tecnológico generó que haya
No es cierto un nivel de supervivencia
muy alto particularmente de niños y de
personas en cierto grado productivas que
lograron extender su vida pero como
contraparte la fecundidad siguió siendo
alto es decir el número de hijos por
mujer siguió siendo alto y eso generó un
cambio dentro de la estructura de edades
que generó una gran población joven y
una tasa de crecimiento poblacional muy
alta entonces las tasas de crecimiento
poblacional que se vieron en el siglo
que son inusitadas para la humanidad
básicamente se produjeron en función de
esta gran transición que llamamos
transición demográfica sin embargo la
fecundidad ha empezado a caer y junto
con la fecundidad disminuyendo se
ralentizado el nivel de crecimiento
para mencionar algunos datos entre entre
1927 y 1960 logramos No es cierto subir
mil millones de personas y la población
creció de 2000 a 3.000 Pero entre el 60
y el 74 los siguientes mil millones solo
tomaron No es cierto 14 años los
siguientes mil millones 13 años los
siguientes mil millones 12 años y así ha
ido disminuyendo este momento empezamos
otra vez a ver el garantice Cómo se
ralentizas de ralentiza este crecimiento
es decir empieza a ver más tiempo Cada
vez que vamos sumando y se espera que
por primera vez en este siglo hacia 2086
la población del mundo se haya
estabilizado es decir va a llegar a un
máximo y ya finalmente no va a seguir
creciendo justamente fruto de la
traducción que existe desde hace rato ya
en la fecundidad en el mundo O sea no es
para preocuparnos Pablo que se esté
dando estas reducción en el ritmo de
crecimiento de la población no es nada
para preocuparnos
No para nada Nosotros de hecho
consideramos que este momento 8000
millones de personas representan 8000
millones de oportunidades para poder
justamente crearnos cierto una sociedad
más resiliente adecuada y también más
justa evidentemente con desafíos pero la
tasa de crecimiento se está ralentizando
entonces este momento vemos un
crecimiento que es básicamente un
inercia en el mundo o sea concepción de
África que es un y de algunas regiones
en el mundo Entonces por ejemplo
Guatemala que son todavía países que
tienen una tasa de fecundidad
relativamente más alta que el promedio
mundial sin embargo en términos
generales más de la mitad de la
población del mundo vive en áreas en
zonas donde la tasa de fecundidad se
encuentra por nivel desde bajo reemplazo
es decir Claro en menos de 2.1 hijos por
mujer en promedio y lo que existe es
esta esta Inercia de que tenemos una
población todavía joven que se sigue
reproduciendo y por eso la población
sigue creciendo vamos a terminar de
complementar este panorama general con
nuestro invitado Javier Maldonado en en
Colombia le damos la bienvenida también
y el mismo Punto de partida Javier Cómo
llegamos a esta cifra Cuál es el
análisis que usted puede hacer cuando
uno habla de estas de estos grandes
números y de un planeta que están
emergencia climática esto tiene cierto
componente digamos apocalíptico nos
preocupamos o no
Bueno muchísimas gracias por la
invitación yo creo que que nuestro
primer invitado pues ha presentado un
panorama muy muy importante en en
Mostrar esto en una tendencia histórica
Sí o sea el número de 8 mil millones es
un número que reacciona mucho digamos
que que llama mucho la atención y creo
que es una oportunidad interesante para
hablar de estos temas poblacionales que
son tan importantes y que muchas veces
pasan desapercibidos dicho eso creo que
que es importante mirar esto
históricamente O sea como como se
señalaba al principio de de esta charla
estamos en un momento de estabilización
de las tasas de crecimiento
especialmente digamos en términos de
fecundidad Ya vimos momentos de mayor
aceleración
esos momentos de mayor aceleración
digamos que correspondieron a momentos
históricos específicos de expansión
digamos de Mercado de expansión
capitalista
incluso las mismas políticas de
fecundidad en algún momento tuvieron
como como y de control poblacional
Estuvieron muy muy atadas misiones muy
grandes del mundo en las que había una
cierta desconfianza hacia el crecimiento
desmesurado a los pobres bajo este
principio malthusiano que es digamos
Sí bueno hemos perdido la conexión con
Javier vamos a restablecer con Javier
allí en Colombia la conexión para
continuar hablando con él mientras tanto
seguimos hablando con a Pablo nuestro
otro invitado en Guatemala Pablo
continuó con usted
leyendo diferentes artículos y análisis
sobre este tema porque es tal vez la
noticia internacional de el día de hoy
se habla de escenarios muy difíciles de
las desigualdades que hay las
diferencias que hay entre los países
ricos y desarrollados como China o como
Estados Unidos que lideran ese top y
otros países menos favorecidos
económicamente que están en áfrica o en
el sudeste asiático pero quiero comenzar
este análisis buscándole El lado
positivo a lo que significa que la
humanidad haya llegado a esta cifra si
estamos en ocho mil millones de personas
en este planeta es porque qué fórmula
nos funcionó que hemos mejorado
principalmente porque logramos reducir
la mortalidad y hemos incrementado
enormemente la esperanza de vida
entonces es un triunfo de la humanidad
es un triunfo de la ciencia es un
triunfo que tenemos No es cierto en
términos de hemos sobrevivido dos
pandemias por ejemplo o sea hemos tenido
la pandemia del VIH y la academia la
pandemia de covid 19 y sin embargo la
población No es cierto Ha logrado
superarlas y este momento sigue No es
cierto en una tendencia entonces existen
esto es una una de las bases que están
allí importantes evidentemente desafíos
pero el otro gran tema es que en general
también hay una mejor o hay hay más
cumplimiento Aunque todavía hay brechas
en la el principio de que las mujeres
tienen que decidir sobre su propia
fecundidad algo que ha ocurrido No es
cierto desde 1994 hasta hoy es que a
pesar de que todavía hay brechas
importantes logramos que en términos
generales las mujeres tengan más poder
de decisión sobre su propia fecundidad
eso ha tenido No es cierto implicaciones
de irreducible la tasa de crecimiento
poblacional y también de incrementar la
participación de las mujeres dentro del
mercado laboral tenemos en general
condiciones que son mucho mejores que
las que teníamos cierto a inicios del
siglo y que brindan oportunidades
totalmente para la población a futuro no
entonces abriendo brechas yo creo que en
términos generales de los dos ámbitos
existen importantes avances tanto en lo
que es igualdad de género y
participación de las mujeres en los
diferentes ámbitos de la humanidad y
también los incrementos importantes
hemos tenido la esperanza de vida y
particularmente la reducción de las
nutriciones de la mortalidad infantil
importante esos puntos que destacan
nuestro invitado Pablo Salazar retomamos
la comunicación con Javier Javier
estábamos hablando de lo positivo que
significa para la humanidad haber
llegado a estas cifras Pablo destaca la
reducción de la mortalidad pero yo le
quiero Añadir el componente de la
tecnología por ejemplo el desarrollo
tecnológico en favor de nuestra
supervivencia y también garantizarnos
diferentes procedimientos médicos que
también nos garantiza pues una mayor
mejor calidad de vida y vidas más
prolongadas que se puede destacar
Completamente de acuerdo con lo que
señalaba Pablo creo que es un logro
digamos llegar a 8.000 millones
evidentemente la tecnología fue es el
factor digamos que que ha hecho que
muchas veces en momentos en los que se
ha se ha pintado digamos un panorama muy
oscuro en otros momentos de la historia
respecto del crecimiento demográfico el
escenario sea diferente Sí entonces la
tecnología nos ha permitido ser mucho
más eficientes en la producción de
alimentos nos ha permitido digamos
Elevar mucho la calidad de vida en
términos de acceso a agua potable
saneamiento básico vacunas medicamentos
sino para por el conocimiento digamos
tecnología científico que está la base
de eso no pondríamos digamos este margen
de maniobras dicho eso digamos que si
bien es un aspecto muy positivo que se
mantenga como un aspecto positivo el
crecimiento poblacional depende también
mucho de decisiones políticas una base
aplicamos el reconocimiento
de que la riqueza de las Naciones es su
gente sí son las personas más que los
recursos Entonces esto en un contexto de
cambio climático va a ser muy importante
porque esa esas 8.000 millones digamos
de oportunidades tiene sentido en tanto
que los estados y digamos los actores
que operan en la economía global
te haga las apuestas correctas hacia
apoyar ese recurso Sí o sea educación
como decía muy bien Pablo la parte
empoderamiento de la mujer es
fundamental o sea tanto por su rol de
cuidadoras como por toda la base que que
proveen a nivel digamos de sostenimiento
de de la sociedad de la familia
mejoramientos en la calidad de vida de
las mujeres mayor acceso a educación
repercute no solo digamos en menores
tasas de fecundidad sino ante todo
también en una mayor producción de valor
social o sea mayor conocimiento
distribuido mayores recursos eso eso va
a ser fundamental y van a emerger temas
importantes de Justicia ambiental porque
digamos que al principio cuando usted se
asociaba un poco en algunos escenarios
se ha asociado
crecimiento poblacional como una
sobrecarga sobre los ecosistemas y como
uno de los factores que está detrás
digamos de la situación de crisis
ambiental que vivimos sino revisar los
números con mayor detalle o buena
perspectiva más histórica un poco
digamos los abusos sobre el planeta no
han sido ejercidos por la mayoría de la
población sino por una élite que sobre
consumen Entonces se hace un par de de
semanas se publicaba un estudio que
hablaba para el caso de Reino Unido pero
creo que nos da luces sobre lo que está
pasando como el 10% más rico de la
población en un año con producen la
misma digamos huella de carbono que el
10% más pobre en 20 años en dos décadas
entonces
buena parte digamos de la sostenibilidad
del planeta va a estar más vinculado a
redistribución a justicia ambiental y no
podemos ver únicamente desde una
perspectiva de sobrecarga por cambio
poblacional es mucho más complejo
Javier continuó con usted creo que
entonces la gran deuda pendiente que
tenemos como humanidad Más allá de haber
logrado estos avances que nos garantiza
prolongar un poco más la vida o tener
una mejor calidad de vida es justamente
cerrar hechas cerrar esas brechas que
hay
de déficit y que hay de diferencias a
nivel económico y a nivel de acceso a
cosas básicas como la educación esto
sigue siendo una deuda pendiente Cómo
hacer para que esto empiece a hacer algo
una agenda global de importancia para
todos los países de forma transversal no
solamente que los países que tienen
posibilidades económicas puedan
garantizar una buena educación sino que
aquellos que no tienen tanto desarrollo
económico lo tenga como un tema central
Bueno yo creo que y en esto estoy
diciendo optimista creo que que la
situación de crisis Global en la que en
la que estamos digamos inmersos se está
empezando a generar más conciencia sobre
lo profundamente interconectados que
estamos entonces
un tema como el poblacional digamos que
que los números que se nos presentan
cuando los vemos desde una perspectiva
planetaria pues muestran una cierto
homogeneidad pero el escenario es muy
diferente a nivel de regiones e incluso
dentro de los mismos países Entonces
siempre se sea como que estaba flechas
entre países desarrollados países en
vías de desarrollo pero un país como
Colombia Como por ejemplo como ejemplo
que es un país de ingreso medio vivimos
las dos situaciones o sea ciudades como
Bogotá como Medellín ya veremos procesos
de envejecimiento en el cual digamos las
tasas de fecundidad han venido bajando
la vida se ha venido prolongando y el
reto ahora es cómo vamos a lidiar con
una sociedad envejecida en términos
digamos de cuidado en términos de
sostenimiento del sistema pensional y
demás y al mismo tiempo vivimos en las
regiones en la costa Caribe en las
periferias del país otro escenario en el
que hay una estrate fecundidad muy altas
en el que digamos que a la mujer no se
le empoderado lo suficiente y siguen
habiendo unas necesidades básicas
insatisfechas que están haciendo que
haya una una importante pero que no
hayan oportunidades entonces creo que
tener una conciencia de esos desbalances
que ocurren no solo a nivel es global
Planetario sino también a nivel local
nacional es fundamental a la hora de
definir políticas claro entonces creo
que la palabra clave va a ser
redistribución en los próximos años
hemos crecido suficiente es hora de
empezar a pensar en términos de
redistribución como el primer mandato
palabra clave primera conclusión grande
que deja este debate lo podemos poner
así Pablo en este momento
es cuando uno llega a ciertos mitos que
hay cuando uno empieza a comparar
algunas regiones del mundo Quiero que
con usted Pablo analicemos el caso de
Europa y el caso de África y de una vez
quitemos todos estos mitos que hay y
entendamos cómo está el panorama porque
en Europa la población
crece tan poco es mucho mayor en
términos de edad se está envejeciendo y
en otros países por ejemplo del sur
global están tiene una población mucho
más joven pero son mucho más pobres en
recursos económicos
está ligada la pobreza al aumento de la
población porque también vemos Que china
no es un país pobre literalmente en todo
el sentido de la palabra y es el país
más poblado del mundo
no existe necesariamente una identidad
No es cierto el tema pero decir que el
crecimiento de la población es parte de
un proceso de desarrollo y es un partido
un proceso de capitalización de las
sociedades de hecho china igual que los
tigres asiáticos que Corea que Japón
claramente muestran Cómo se puede
utilizar Y aprovechar el crecimiento de
la población joven para poder sacarle
provecho a lo que se llama el bono
demográfico que es la oportunidad que
tenemos Y que todos los países tenemos
de tener una base grande de población en
edad de trabajar que a su vez permiten
un cierto mantener a una población que
se va reduciendo relativamente que la
población dependiente tanto de niños
como de adultos mayores en los inicios
de este etapa media de la transición
demográfica Entonces los países
africanos particularmente están etapas
muy iniciales de la transición
demográfica donde todavía hay tasas de
fecundidad muy altas y donde la la ha
habido No es cierto una experiencia
reciente de empezar a reducir y ampliar
fuertemente No es cierto la esperanza de
vida entonces son países que están
experimentando este proceso también son
países muy Rurales que están empezando a
hacer transición hacia los niveles
urbanos y poco a poco se espera que esas
tasas van a ir convergiendo esa es la
razón por la cual el mundo va a empezar
a tener No es cierto una estabilización
de la población pero diciendo que sí
efectivamente África va a ser la única
Región del mundo que va a estar hacia
finales de Tito todavía creciendo
países como Europa la tasa de fecundidad
se encuentra por debajo del nivel de
reemplazo desde hace mucho tiempo la
razón por la cual en algunos de esos
países todavía la población no cae en
términos de absolutos es también por el
fenómeno migratorio hay que ver en la
migración ese proceso también de
redistributivo que podría existir entre
el norte global y el azul global para
poder equilibrarnos en ciertos
sociedades que necesitan personas
jóvenes con cierto oportunidades para
esas personas jóvenes que se encuentran
No es cierto en otros lugares y otras
latitudes claro
pasó a preguntarle a Javier entonces
teniendo este esta foto un poco más
clara de estos dos continentes Cuál va a
ser Entonces el reto de África porque es
un país que se está
modernizando en su infraestructura está
en un proceso de transición Como dice
Pablo pasar de ser un continente muy
rural a densificar un poco más las zonas
urbanas pero que también necesita una
evolución rápida en cuanto a servicios
hospitales educación es un gran esfuerzo
que van a tener que hacer allí los
gobiernos pero que tantos recursos hay
Cuál va a ser el reto de este continente
Sí yo creo que evidentemente unos retos
locales nacionales incluso de región en
términos digamos de de como decía Pablo
pues aprovechar al máximo este recurso o
sea una población tan joven es
determinante en los procesos de
desarrollo pero pues lo que detona
digamos el desarrollo es que se invierta
en esa población Entonces ese educación
empoderamiento a la mujer van a ser como
partes parte fundamental de este proceso
por otra parte también una
responsabilidad es como más planetarias
más globales que de alguna forma ya
están empezando a verse digamos que
el crecimiento poblacional es como unos
primos indicadores Hacia dónde va el
desarrollo entonces a nivel histórico
esas expansiones han venido acompañadas
de los centros geopolíticos y de
economía del mundo Entonces una primera
expansión ocurre en Europa occidental y
ocurre digamos con el posicionamiento de
Europa luego Estados Unidos como como
líderes de y occidente como líderes de
los mercados en los últimos 50 años
vimos para el paulatino no ausenso de
Asia de China Japón
digamos de de la Cuenca del Pacífico y
eso vino acompañado digamos primero de
una avanzada poblacional luego de mucho
desarrollo y Bueno ahí digamos hay toda
una posición cultural muy importante
creo que en los próximos años África va
a empezar a tomar ese lugar entonces
Ahorita hay mucho interés digamos de
muchos actores a nivel internacional en
invertir en la región va a ser digamos
un área de disputa también por poderes
más hegemónicos por ejercer digamos sus
estrategias de dominación porque hacía
Ya basta la expansión más importante de
población mercados y demás pero creo que
también veremos como como un Renacer
digamos de de África en el sentido de
ser el referente para la humanidad en
los próximos años como ha pasado con los
otros con los otros digamos centros
geopolíticos Y eso va a ser muy
interesante va a ser digamos un
reposicionamiento de África como como en
términos culturales en términos también
de globalización y demás que creo que va
a ser muy interesante y Pablo Y qué hay
del caso de China ya va mucho la
atención que sigue siendo el país más
poblado del mundo después de haber
tenido unas políticas demográficas tan
rigurosas el gobierno comunista allí en
ha sido fue criticado durante muchos
años por estas políticas sobre todo en
las zonas urbanas de ese país qué
lecciones deja esas políticas de China y
tener a este país asiático ahora
liderando el ranking de los países más
poblados del mundo y se espera que el
año entrante India lo supere ya vamos a
hablar del caso de India
también general decir que tanto en China
como en India este momento la fecundidad
es una fecundidad por debajo del nivel
de reemplazo decir
nacen menos niños no es cierto la
práctica cada cada año y lo que ha
impulsado todavía el crecimiento de
estos dos países es lo que llamamos el
momento demográfico ahora desde el punto
de vista de de una de una dimensión que
no hemos mencionado hay que hay que
plantear que justamente el modelo de
hijo único en China es un poco la
antítesis de lo que se busca en términos
generales a través de los diferentes
instrumentos de política que que está en
este momento vigentes para poder
garantizar la igualdad de las mujeres
que es que las mujeres puedan decidir
directa y de una forma libre voluntaria
No es cierto cuando cuantos y dónde y
cuándo y con quién quieren tener sus
hijos pues la política elijo único es
una política que no va en la línea de
derechos sexuales y reproductivos el
ejercicio de los Derechos productivos
que son las mujeres y parte de ese tema
ese que observamos ahora es
cura bastante envejecida por ejemplo de
la población de China donde hay grandes
desafíos en este momento para la
sostenibilidad en el mediano plazo de
los sistemas que podrían garantizar
justamente el bienestar de esa población
y y un desequilibrio en términos
generales en términos de la población
productiva más temas que tienen relación
También con la formación de familias
entonces en términos generales la
recomendación que uno puede hacer
siempre en términos de profesionales es
Buscar justamente que las políticas de
fecundidad se base en las decisiones
libres de las mujeres tomadas en base a
información adecuada correcta y a sus
propios niveles de empoderamiento no
Entonces es algo que hemos aprendido de
la experiencia de China la necesidad de
no tener objetivos profesionales sino de
que justamente se pueda trabajar en
función de de las decisiones de las
mujeres y la forma como ellas están
ejerciendo las en el contexto de
crecimiento demo entonces ahí hay un
primer decir que este momento china es
es este que están enfrentando
seriamente el tema de de de del reto del
envejecimiento vocacional tiene usted
veráscripciones sobre las políticas del
estado de las de baja fecundidad
probablemente con el mediano plazo china
va a tener que considerar una política
migratoria que ayude a mantener la
fuerza laboral además de cambios
importantes para poder suplantar
eventualmente trabajadores a través de
robotización por ejemplo no pero uno uno
encuentra este tipo de desfases de este
momento en el mercado laboral en China
Javier hemos hablado del déficit en
cuanto a materias primas los retos son
muchos en materia
medioambiental y el planeta Pues ya hay
algunos países que requieren más de un
planeta para poder sostener sus cadenas
productivas esto hablando de un caso
cercano por ejemplo Estados Unidos que
es un país que requiere muchísimos
recursos para sostener su economía en
pie qué tan preocupante es este consumo
tan alto que tenemos de las materias
primas en este momento que ya consumimos
los recursos del planeta antes de los
dos de finalizar los 12 meses del año y
con este nivel de crecimiento de la
población
Sí aquí de nuevo el tema de Justicia
ambiental y si se quisiera digamos de
alguna justicia demográfica es
fundamental como usted lo señala a la
hora digamos de los impactos los
impactos son planetarios pero no son
toda la humanidad La que está
consumiendo y no son digamos aquellos
Centros donde está más Dinámico el
crecimiento poblacional en el que se
está concentrando el consumo sino son
digamos los países del Norte global
países industrializados países que
digamos se han construido unas culturas
de consumo y unas culturas del exceso
que están llevando digamos y arrastrando
a los demás países
eso definitiva y es el problema digamos
de poder tomar acciones frente a eso son
Son problemas globales que no necesitan
acciones globales y para ciertas áreas
digamos de de del mundo ciertas
economías va a implicar digamos un
cambio profundo en las formas como se
consume y en las formas de vida Sí en
Colombia se ha venido hablando en los
últimos meses del concepto de
crecimiento ha sido muy polémico digamos
por porque hay unas visiones de
crecimiento económico que son vistas
como la una buena opción pero creo que
un escenario mayor sostenibilidad y
mayor justicia distributiva y Justicia
ambiental va a pasar necesariamente por
un decrecimiento en aquellas economías
que que han tenido un crecimiento casi
patógenos si se quisiera por la forma en
la que han digamos devorado recursos y
pues como usted mismo lo señala eso eso
no es sostenible
en Javier también hemos Tenemos que
hablar del tema medioambiental
justamente estamos en en la semana final
de la Copa 27 se firman muchísimos
acuerdos hay muchos compromisos pero
poca acción que es tal vez lo que se le
ha criticado a esta Cumbre climática a
nivel internacional muchos compromisos
por parte de los gobiernos mucho
protocolo pero poca capacidad de
realizar esos planos Esos planes en
terreno de continuar el cambio climático
como vamos sabemos las consecuencias que
esto va a traer escasez de alimentos
escasez de agua y por ejemplo
efectos atmosféricos adversos mayor ya
de huracanes o tormentas inundaciones y
también el aumento en el nivel de los
océanos Esto va a obligar a que haya
desplazamientos de grandes cantidades de
personas hacia otros lugares y la
población sigue creciendo Esto va a
llevar a que se concentren que se armen
algunos puntos de concentración de de o
que se formen núcleos urbanos muchísimo
más densamente poblados donde tampoco
hay recursos para garantizarles a todos
yo creo que que la siguiente vamos fase
tiene que ser de un desarrollo
tecnológico muy en línea digamos de
sostenibilidad y de solidaridad
evidentemente no podemos seguir con el
mismo modelo de desarrollo y con las
mismas prácticas que hemos seguido hasta
el momento
hay unos retos muy importantes y como
usted señala digamos que que hay una
fuerza adicional en todo este escenario
demográfico que es lo ambiental y ya
estamos empezando a vivirlo digamos que
no son hace escena problemas que no ven
un escenario futuro en este momento
digamos que hay algunos estudios que
hablan también por ejemplo toda la ola
migratoria centroamericana hacia Estados
Unidos como este pico que estamos
viviendo está muy bien cuidado también a
problemas ambientales en un país como
Colombia en este momento estamos
experimentando una emergencia invernal
muy fuerte el clima digamos que ha
tenido unos patrones bastante
complicados en los últimos dos años y
todo esto hace parte digamos de los
desbalances que ya estamos empezando a
sufrir y empieza a ser un poco
frustrante como usted señala Pues que
los espacios de decisión global se
avanza muy poco y que en este termina
sufriendo son digamos los países mundial
de desarrollo y entre los países
enviados de desarrollo aquellos que
están en una situación mayor de
vulnerabilidad ese va a ser un reto
digamos que para que este llegar a los
8.000 millones de personas sea en
realidad
la oportunidad que que está ahí a la
base y vamos a aprovechar todo ese
recurso va a implicar unos cambios
importantes mucha solidaridad y digamos
que
apoyar estas poblaciones Porque si
ustedes se dan cuenta los lugares
digamos son los que está concentrado
usted que el crecimiento poblacional y
que van a tener lugar muy importante en
los próximos años también son lugares
muy vulnerables climáticamente estamos
hablando de África estamos hablando de
la India en la India misma ha sido
interesante ver la misma división o sea
el norte se está creciendo a unas tasas
muy muy amplias Mientras que el sur ya
está estabilizado Entonces estamos
viviendo como a nivel local incluso
muchos escenarios que uno pintaba de
forma global envejecimiento para ciertas
áreas para ciertos grupos sociales y
otros en los que hay una gran
oportunidad de utilizar ese recurso pero
se necesita inversión Claro a mí me
llama mucho que justamente cuando
mencionaba los cinco países menos
poblados del mundo mencionaba tres
estados insulares de Oceanía que son
países que están al borde de desaparecer
ya han perdido muchísimo terreno
muchísimo de su superficie debido al
aumento en el nivel de los de los
océanos o bueno por lo menos del océano
Pacífico está hablando de tuvaluna y de
palao casos Como esos hay muchísimos más
no solo en el Pacífico sino también en
territorios insulares por ejemplo en el
Caribe ya hemos retomado la conexión con
Pablo Quiero preguntarle estábamos
viendo también el caso de China Ahora
quiero que veamos el caso de la India un
país llama mucho la atención la
composición económica social que tiene
es un país enorme territorialmente
hablando y pues obviamente su población
también es una de las tres más
destacadas en el planeta pero se estima
que para el 2023 pase a ser el número
uno como el país más poblado del mundo
Qué retos tiene este país
India todavía es un país que tiene
muchísimas desigualdades como se
mencionaba o sea es un país No es cierto
que tiene diferentes ritmos que tiene No
es cierto todavía grandes zonas Rurales
tiene todavía mucho espacio en términos
de poder consolidar algunas de las
transiciones demográficas pero claro
tiene en promedio este momento tiene una
fecundidad por debajo del nivel de
reemplazo y lo que ha mantenido
creciendo a la India A diferencia de de
China de su vecino es que tiene No es
cierto una estructura poblacional más
joven donde todavía tiene una una
preeminencia de población en edad de
trabajar entonces
India todavía tiene esta este tema Pero
sigue siendo No es cierto cuna y te
decía es uno de los lugares No es cierto
que más concentran por ejemplo la
pobreza en el mundo por justamente la
dimensión que tiene el país hay todavía
grandes retos en términos de inclusión
de poder lograr efectivamente un
desarrollo y que permite inclusivo que
permita No es cierto de grandes y
grandes contingentes de personas puedan
incorporarse No es cierto a esa
autodesarrollo pero también es un país
que está creciendo dentro de la economía
es fuertes no pensar que en algún
momento hubo un bloque específico por
ejemplo entre Brasil Sudáfrica India
China No es cierto que buscaban tener un
eje de diferente justamente de
crecimiento en el mundo y y alrededor de
eso india sin duda es uno de los países
que más potencial va a tener empezamos a
verlo dentro de la Esfera tecnológica
dentro de la feria industrial y sin duda
Tuvo una gran preeminencia en la
fabricación de vacunas y probablemente
va a ser también una de las uno uno de
los países no es cierto donde se van a
concentrar el desarrollo económico en
las próximas décadas y también rodeado
por los países más poblados del mundo
está por un lado rodado por Pakistán al
otro lado tiene bangladesh al norte
tiene China es es una zona densamente
poblada en términos de habitantes en
nuestro planeta un tema muy interesante
se nos acaba el tiempo eh Pablo Javier
yo agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros hoy en el programa dimos por lo
menos un análisis de los temas clave
relacionados con esta fecha importante
los 8.000 millones de habitantes que ya
tenemos en nuestro planeta Muchas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros el
nombre del equipo técnico también las
agradecemos su sintonía la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Giovanni
a agudelo y la producción de invitados
estuvo a cargo de Samuel Salgado y de
Tania Herrera siga con nosotros
[Música]